le premier ministre du québec a fait sa
première intervention dans la campagne
électorale fédérale beaucoup plus
réservé que kathleen wynne son homologue
de l'ontario fait l'écho hier à formuler
ses demandes pour la province aux chefs
des partis fédéraux
mais david et s'en est pris aussi aux
parfums au chef du parti québécois était
premier ministre philippe couillard a
est formel il ne laissera pas un pouce
aux souverainistes québécois at il dit
aujourd'hui veut répondre coup pour coup
aux arguments qui sont mis de l'avant
par le chef péquiste pierre karl
péladeau pour monsieur couillard c'est
clair l'accession du québec à la
souveraineté se traduirait par
d'importants problèmes entre autres
économique pour les québécois et ce sur
une longue période
botté d'envoi de la saison politique
pour le chef libéral qui lance déjà une
attaque dans le camp souverainiste mieux
que de longs aux années de souffrances
et difficultés économiques et
financières et diminution du niveau de
vie des québécois pierre karl péladeau
occulte les conséquences de
l'indépendance selon philippe couillard
qui a l'intention de répliquer coup pour
coup
ce que j'ai décidé de faire c'est que je
laisserai pas un pouce pour s'ouvrir
pas question pourtant de projeter
l'image de premier ministre soumis face
à ottawa
il profite de la campagne fédérale pour
proposer aux parties de revenir à
l'esprit de la fédération et de
respecter les champs de compétence
provinciaux on a malheureusement assisté
à des gestes unilatéraux pas uniquement
au cours des dernières années également
les années précédentes sur des questions
telles que les transferts financiers par
exemple et parfois les intrusions dans
les champs de compétence provinciale
québec souhaite aussi entendre les
partis fédéraux sur les transferts en
santé secteur où ottawa assume une part
qui diminue depuis des années
québec veut aussi plus d'argent pour les
infrastructures et des engagements des
partis fédéraux sur la question des
changements climatiques au plan
constitutionnel
le premier ministre lance un
avertissement tout changement devra
inclure des discussions sur les demandes
traditionnelles du québec
s'il y avait un jour convocation d'une
table de discussion forcément conscio
neil sur le sénat le québec n'ira pas à
moins que les enjeux qui demeure
toujours d'actualité les demandes
traditionnelles du québec demain
l'actualité soit également ce matin
philippe couillard affirme qu'il n'a pas
d'échéancier constitutionnel précis et
qu'il n'a pas non plus l'intention
d'initier des pourparlers à ce sujet ici
david gentilles radio canada shawinigan